three groups had this letter that was
requested to be anonymous Dianne
Feinstein and her staff the
congresswoman from California and her
staff and the lawyers somebody betrayed
her trust and if you can't figure out
why you shouldn't be driving
Christine Ford had wanted to remain
anonymous she did want to testify
yesterday she want anyone to know her
name she only went public with her
allegations after somebody leaked them
to the press just a few weeks ago only a
few people knew knew about the letter
that she written to congressman an issue
and that it made its way to Senator
Dianne Feinstein's office and from one
of those offices her identity made it to
reporters who did that and why aren't
Democrats interested in finding out the
identity of the person who did that
since supposedly they care so deeply
about Christine Ford Andy McCarthy was
an assistant US attorney for the
Southern District of New York Jodi
genival is a US attorney in Washington
they both join us giant Andy to you
first why would it be so hard to find
out how this information got from one of
two congressional offices to the
Washington Post Tucker if we assume that
it had to be one of those two offices
then it should be a small world of
people I think the problem that we have
factually is that the first press outlet
who got it the intercept now says that
Feinstein senator Feinstein was not the
source that doesn't mean that the other
California Congress critter as you point
out could not be the source or that it
could have come for the lawyers or
perhaps a an acquaintance a friend of
dr. Ford but while it's a small amount
of people who are in the circle of the
possible leaker and if you made an
aggressive investigation you might be
able to get some leads quickly certainly
if Cavanaugh can be or investigated
seven times you'd think that this might
be at least worth a once-over well you
would think that I'm generally
interested if you cared about Christine
Ford wouldn't you care deeply about who
betrayed her and overturned her life
what
she would but this is not what it's
about for the Democrats this is not
about ethics or morality or rightness
it's about power the Democrats leaked
this
her lawyers leaked it maybe she leaked
it somebody or her family leaked it we
know one thing
it wasn't the Republicans who leaked it
because they didn't have the letter so
it was somebody who wanted to use her
and to make it part of the process of
trying to just Flay away at Judge
Cavanaugh this is part of the disgusting
display that the Democrats have created
they're trying to make it look like it's
something that's serious
in fact it's awful and it's demeaning
the country it's the meaning the Senate
I don't know what effect it's having on
Miss doctor Ford or whatever her name is
the bottom line is this is an attempt to
destroy a good man in his family and the
Democrats are succeeding and they got
their delay on the vote on the Senate
floor and they may ultimately win so
that's for sure so any McCarthy you've
watched this for the last two weeks I'm
sure you've been as riveted as the rest
of us you follow this stuff already for
a living what's your I mean give me a
30-second take away what do you make of
all this what have you learned that it's
it's just phenomenal that the Democrats
could not more clearly signal that what
this is all about is delay delay delay
no matter what they're talking about
whether it's you know the victims or the
survivors or somebody's privacy or the
need for an FBI investigation it's all
about delay and yet the Republicans seem
to think if we just give them a little
bit more delay we can bring this thing
to closure and I just for the for the
life of me I can't wrap my brain around
that I can't either have you ever seen
anything this cynical honestly you've
been here a long time now you know I
came here in 1967 fifty-one years ago I
have never seen anything like this and
to watch senator Coons today do that
unto us just supercilious description of
how how wonderful it was to work with
senator flake and how well all we wanted
was just a little bit more time I mean
this goofy disgusting performance by the
Democrats you know the Senate used to be
a beautiful place it's now a very very
ugly place and the American people are
being justjust harmed by this it's awful
it's
awful for the country and that Democrats
don't care one whit because all they
care about is power it's true Andy Joe
thank you both very much I hope you get
a weekend away from all this I'm gonna
try to